[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 26 juin bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 7,8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
la france a fait match nul 0 à 0 dans
son dernier match de groupe face au
danemark
elle nous serons dans un instant à bois
d'arcy la commune propose de voir les
matchs des bleus à la coupe du monde sur
écran géant un bon parcours tricolore
pourrait-il avoir un impact positif sur
le football yvelinois éléments de
réponse avec notre invité fatna hdmi du
district des yvelines
l'autre grande compétition sportive
cette année arrive en septembre sur le
territoire c'est la ryder cup qui se
prépare à saint quentin en yvelines
à moins de 100 jours de l'événement une
réunion pour présenter la logistique se
tenait hier à guyancourt
enfin ils ont pu voyager tout en restant
elancourt les élèves de l'école alain
cavalier ont travaillé cette année sur
les pays étrangers pour ce faire ces
jeunes échangent régulièrement avec deux
étudiants globe trotter parti faire le
tour du monde
le mouvement dure depuis trois mois a la
sncf les cheminots entament à partir de
demain la deuxième la dernière phase
pardon de leurs grèves dites perlé elle
prendra fin officiellement ce jeudi des
perturbations
elles sont donc encore à prévoir à saint
quentin en yvelines ce sont les mêmes
depuis quelques semaines un trafic
réduit de moitié c'est un train sur deux
pour le rer c la ligne n ai eu du
transilien
les horaires de vos trains sont à
retrouver sur transilien.com est à noter
que la mobilisation unitaire des
syndicats des cheminots prendra fin ce
jeudi mais pour rappel la cgt cheminots
appelle de nouveau à la grève cet été un
premier préavis déposés pour les
journées du 6 et 7 juillet vous l'avez
sûrement suivi il ya quelques instants
le match nul de l'équipe de france de
football face au danemark 0 à 0 dans le
dernier match de poule à la coupe du
monde en russie
on retrouve tout de suite depuis la mjc
l'abri blues à bois d'arcy michael mino
robond soir alors vous avez suivi
michael sur place la rencontre des bleus
oui effectivement un grégory j'étais à
l'abri blues de bois d'arcy je peux vous
dire que les supporters ont vibré ici
malheureusement il n'y a pas eu de but 0
à 0 un triste 0-0 mais
à mes côtés bibi naceri qui a su avec
attention cette rencontre et qui a vibré
au rythme des débordements de l'est marc
par exemple ou de dembélé
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de ce
match c'était match de poule dernier
match de poule la france était qualifiée
sa match fermé pour être honnête c'est
un match fermé la france avait sept
points là maintenant le danemark est
qualifiée aussi les deux équipes étaient
qualifiées de temps au pérou avait battu
l'australie donc il n'y avait plus
d'enjeu et ils ont fait tourner la balle
vous attendiez à ce type de rencontre
wissant général les types de rencontres
de fans poule comme on dit donc les deux
équipes étaient déjà qualifiées s'était
pas y avait pas d'enjeu c'est pas comme
ils n'y arriveront le portugal ou
l'espagne et le maroc donc c'était un
match de transition je pense de
transition est ce qu'il ya des séquences
de jeu qui vous ont énervé par exemple
en attaque on a vu de nombreux tirs non
cadrés par les français
finalement c'est peut-être le problème
offensif qui a fait défaut à la france
aujourd'hui
plus largement je pense que c'est
l'animation il ya eu très peu de
remontées de balle giroux était très
esseulé en grande forme et je pense
qu'il va l'être en huitièmes de finale
je pense qu'ils ont fait tourner la
balle mba paix entre extrêmement tard je
pense qu'un 80/85 je sais plus je pense
qu'il ya un problème global d'animation
il ya un très très bon très bonne
défense mais je pense qu'il est dan
aussi remis une très très bonne défense
aujourd'hui
donc voilà ils ont géré si vous voulez
la qualification les deux équipes roger
rey la qualification est ce que vous
pensez qu'ici les ondes positives ont
été envoyés aux français pour remporter
ce match ici à l'abri blues de bois
d'arcy
disons que la salle était pleine comme
le stade loujniki aujourd'hui la salle
était pleine
il y avait beaucoup de jeunes c'est
l'objectif au site de la bri blues
puisque c'est notre service jeunesse ici
donc c'est une très très belle salle et
c'est là on retransmet les matchs de
l'équipe de france de football et de
rugby dont il y avait une centaine de
personnes est ce que c'est le cas tous
les matches de l'équipe de france s'est
plaint tout le temps le premier match
france australie on a dû rajouter des
déchets ce parce que c'était plein
l'horaire n'est pas facile
et en plus avec cet horaire là on a
réussi quand même à remplir la salle
l'abribus et un vrai un vrai lieu
culturel aurait lieu d'animation et un
lieu événementiel sur bois d'arcy donc
on remplit
on remplit facilement donc il n'ya pas
de fan zone dans les yvelines
est ce que vous considérez que cette
seule commune fan zone c'est la fan zone
des yvelines voilà c'est une sorte de
fan zone c'est vrai qu' il n'est pas
trop d'ambiance ne faillirai pas
beaucoup d'enjeu mais je suis persuadé
que pour le 8e de finale c'est samedi je
prends ça va être plein avec plein d co
plein de plans de maquillage prennent
jeunes ça va être une grosse ambiance à
l'abribus et est ce que c'est votre
initiative
cette cette opération à l'abri blues ou
est ce que c'est une décision de jeu
c'est pas de certaines personnes de la
bible non c'est une décision de la
mairie on a décidé depuis quelques
années maintenant de retransmettre les
grands matchs de l'équipe de france à
l'abri blues on a fait la coupe du monde
de rugby on a fait la coupe de cheveux à
d'europe en 2016 et on a fait la coupe
du monde 2018 donc ça devient une
tradition on a lancé une belle idée ça
devient une tradition maintenant bois
d'arcy est une ville sportive
oui vraiment honnêtement bon je vais pas
dire c'était pas une ville sportive en
tant que maire de boissy et très
honnêtement on a une paris nice l'année
dernière on est une variété qui est venu
aujourd'hui on rénove tous nos
équipements
on a fait la piste d'athlétisme autour
de la du terrain d'honneur on a rénové
les équipements de foot en train de
rénover notre plus grand gymnase on
devient vraiment ville de de sport est
on est on a été labellisé cette année
ville du sportif
dernière question avant de vous laisser
à vos activités
votre pronostic pour le prochain match
alors il faut savoir qui parce que la
france va rencontrer soit l'islande sur
l'argentine je croyais peut-être le
niger le nigéria oui c'est vrai pas
évident on a déjà battu nigeria la
dernière coupe du monde mais
moi je prendrais bien en premier
d'islande kristinn l'argentine faut
faire attention toujours attention avec
les argentins merci beaucoup philippe
benassaya vous l'aurez compris il faudra
avoir soit nigeria soit l'islande pour
espérer se qualifier
le prochain match de l'équipe de france
ici à l'abri blues ce sera ce samedi à
16h à bois d'arcy michael on connaîtra
l'adversaire de l'équipe de france ce
soir à 20 heures avec la suite des
matchs de cette coupe du monde merci à
vous et à patrick jacques de dixmude aux
moyens techniques on continue à parler
football dans cette édition une question
plus local quel est l'impact de cette
coupe du monde et des performances des
bleus sur le football yvelinois pour y
répondre une invitée avec moi en plateau
fat nage daini bonsoir à vous êtes
membre du comité de direction du
district de football des yvelines alors
avant de répondre à cette question et
aussi de parler de football féminin
puisque vous êtes membre de la
commission foot féminin dans le
département une première question à la
supportrice des bleus qu'avez vous pensé
de ce match
aujourd'hui 0 à 0 face au danemark j'ai
trouvé ça c'est passable c'est vraiment
dommage parce qu'on aurait souhaité voir
une équipe de france un peu plus
persuasifs un peu plus voir et qui est
un petit peu plus de choses à voir et
des buts aussi puisque je pense que tout
le monde aimerait bien voir justement un
petit défilé de buts et je trouve ça
vraiment dommage parce qu'on dise avait
déjà d' avance qu'ils étaient voilà qui
a qualifié de succès ces dernières
places en jeu ils ont obtenu grâce à ce
match nul faut retenir ça c'est cette
première place c'est cette première
place c'est ce qu'il faut dire les
moyens d'aller loin cette équipe de
france selon vous il faudrait qu'il
faudrait qu'elle ose peut-être son
niveau de jeu proposé plus de spectacles
en tout cas c'est une équipe de france
efficace je pense que on a bien vu qu'il
y avait une très bonne cohésion de
groupe
entrons donc si ça continue comme ça
il ya possibilité justement d'aller un
petit peu plus haut et je pense qu'ils
ont la possibilité de le faire
une équipe de france en 8e de finale et
est première de son groupe c'est
forcément une bonne nouvelle aussi pour
le district de football pour les
français pour l'ensemble des français
alors on rappelle qu'en 2014
après le beau parcours des bleus au
mondial au brésil c'était une défaite à
l'époque contre les futurs champions du
monde allemands le district de football
des yvelines avait enregistré l'époque
18 % de licenciés en plus ça veut dire
que une bonne performance des bleus dans
un mondial a un impact positif sur le
football dans le département il ya un
très gros impact faut savoir que dans
les îles hui nous avons à peu près un
peu plus de quarante mille licenciés
nous sommes comme indice rica c'est un
assez important et à chaque coupe du
monde coupe d'europe il ya toujours un
impact énorme et non sur le territoire
des villes il ya sept ce centre
technique national à clairefontaine
le paris saint germain aussi qui
s'entraînent sur le clairefontaine sur
notre département d'avoir également le
centre tu parais saint-james voir dans
les yvelines puisqu'il ira prochainement
impossible et que ça soit pour les
filles ou les garçons parce qu'on a
quand même la ligue donc des garçons et
puis l'adn défi qu'est ce que même un
trait voilà alors sur l'impact positif
que pas avoir une coupe du monde sûre
des clubs
hibino je vous propose d'écouter tout de
suite le président d'honneur de l'étoile
sportive de trappes
il ya une telle concentration de match
une telle concentration d'image une
telle concentration de stars finalement
c'est notre festival de cannes tous les
quatre ans
et puis et puis les faits encore une
fois nation donc la france en
particulier
forcément
bah forcément oui il ya il ya cet
engagement particulier ce que dit
moustafa larbaoui finalement c'est que
la coupe du monde c'est un peu le
festival de cannes pour pour les footeux
c'est c'est le cas aussi sur les i mean
ya toujours une émulation au moment de
cette coupe du monde dans le territoire
c'est énorme ça ne ça ne changera pas et
et d'année en année quand on passe voilà
deux coupes du monde en coupe d'europe
on remarque voit que ça fait un festival
est ce qu a contrario une mauvaise
performance des scandales aussi quand il
ya pu y en avoir en afrique du sud en
2010 c'est des joueurs qui refusent de
s'entraîner ce que ça peut aussi a
contrario avoir un impact négatif non
parce que je pense que
justement que les clubs font un travail
à ce niveau là avec les joueurs donc on
la respecte quand meme est une chose et
je pense pas que ça puisse avoir un
impact négatif alors je rappelle fat
majdanik vous est également membre de la
commission du football féminin au
district des yvelines deux dates
importantes à retenir pour le football
féminin qui arrivent en france d'abord
le mondial u20 qui se déroulera cet été
en bretagne et la coupe du monde
féminine qui aura lieu en france l'an
prochain
si on doit faire déjà un état des lieux
global du foot féminin et de son
développement dans les éviers est-ce
qu'on est en retard en avance par
rapport à d'autres départements qu'elle
est à quel stade secondes du tout parce
que ces quatre dernières années nous
avons remarqué quand même une nette
augmentation un peu plus de
voilà de 90 % de licenciés
d'accord mais ses filiales et c'est sur
toutes les catégories
que ce soit des petits torrents russie
ce jusqu en jusqu'en seniors et non non
non on a remarquablement une nette
augmentation à ce niveau là et je pense
que la coupe du monde justement ça va
être aussi un tremplin justement à ce
niveau là d'abord aussi des équipes ont
parlé tout à l'heure du paris
saint-germain les féminines du paris
saint germain joue dans les yvelines au
camp des loges elles joueront également
apprécié d'avoir aussi des équipes comme
montini qui évolue et il ya encore
quelques années en d2 féminine ça aide
aussi à faire parler du foot féminin
oui puis dans le département nous avons
quand même quelques gros clubs qui
jouent quand même un niveau très haut
niveau dh comme quoi si mon manque la
zolie enfin nous avons quand même des
clubs phares pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas c'est plus au niveau
régional qui existent au football si çà
et là du coup on parlait des deux
compétitions qui arrive ce mondial u20
cette année en france la coupe du monde
féminine
l'an prochain on sait qu'il ya des
audiences aussi télé qui sont en nette
augmentation de d'année en année quand
avec les bleus au féminin à la télé
quand on est au district de football des
mines on l'attend avec impatience est
cette coupe du monde c'est ça et on y
travaille aussi je le remplace par
exemple on essaye justement
au niveau des jeunes pour des clubs qui
n'ont pas du tout 2 voilà deux
deux filles et on essaie justement de
leur mettre en place des matis toya des
compétitions au niveau des toutes
petites où elles vont entrer là tout au
long de l'année on a aussi des
opérations au niveau des villes qui sont
mises en place pour favoriser justement
cette frappe a visé justement de cette
pratique là et je pense que là ça va
être
je pense qu'on va et qu'on va dépasser
un peu tous les records à ce niveau là
avec cette coupe du monde qui je le
rappelle arrive blanc l'an prochain en
français le mondial u20 pour les jeunes
ça sera dit cet été en bretagne
merci fat nage dernier d'abord être avec
nous je rappelle membre du comité de
direction du district de football des
yvelines autre grande compétition dans
93 jours c'est le coup d'envoi de la
ryder cup à saint quentin en yvelines
alors pour acheminer les deux cent
cinquante mille supporters attendus et
les organisateurs ont mis en place un
plan transport avec des navettes et des
parcs relais autour du site du golf
national
un dispositif présenté ce lundi soir aux
habitants à l'école mansart de
guyancourt reportage de michael et demi
d'euros fermetures de rues conditions de
circulation l'impact de la ryder cup sur
le trafic et la vie des habitants
question ce lundi 25 jours à l'école
mansart de guyancourt pour assurer le
comité d'organisation de l'épreuve
étaient présents pour exposer le
dispositif ya bien entendu des
inquiétudes puisque l'inconnu fait peur
et tant qu'on n'est pas informée sur
l'organisation d'un événement on peut
effectivement que avoir quelques
appréhensions et c'est le but de ma
présence ce soir dans ce très bon public
d'apporter des réponses à toutes les
questions posées par les riverains pour
limiter les craintes pour limiter les
fantasmes et que chacun sache comment
sera organisée la ryder cup
et puis en fonction prendre ses
dispositions pour absorber un flux de
250 mille spectateurs du 25 au 30
septembre prochain du navettes routières
seront mises en place au départ de la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines quatre
parcs relais seront également créées
pour stationner à versailles
louveciennes horse et toussus-le-noble
pour le staff et les vip la ryder cup ce
n'est pas un événement classique car à
la différence d'un match au stade de
france les infrastructures actuelles du
coach national ne sont pas taillés pour
accueillir soixante mille spectateurs
la différence d'un stade de france qui a
été conçu avec des infrastructures
routières et de transport collectif
adapté
on doit la de manière temporaire créé un
plan de transport qui permettent
d'acheminer tout le monde du golf
national
après une heure de questions réponses
avec les organisateurs premier verdict
pour les 50 riverains présents dans la
salle ça nous a permis au moins de
savoir exactement comment l'événement à
les ai roulé ça m'a plutôt rassuré parce
que j'ai vu que le trafic routier
devrait être bien maîtrisée dans les
prochaines semaines d'autres réunions
d'information seront organisées à saint
quentin en yvelines les détails complets
sur la circulation pendant la ryder cup
seront diffusés dans les magazines
municipaux à la rentrée et la prochaine
réunion a lieu dès ce soir mardi à
voisins le bretonneux c'est à la salle
du conseil municipal à partir de 19h le
service est présent à paris et dans 97
communes de l'île de france
autolib cessera définitivement de
fonctionner le 31 juillet et le syndicat
autolib vélib métropole et le groupe
bolloré gestionnaires sont parvenus à un
accord pour une fin programmée de ce
système de partage de véhicules
électriques un motif les pertes
constantes d'autolib chiffré à près de
300 millions d'euros
mais pour le chesnay qui possède cinq
stations et une capacité de 30 voitures
le compte n'y est pas la ville
yvelinoise compte s'associer avec
d'autres communes pour une action en
justice selon son maire la fin du
service n'était pas inéluctable
ils dénoncent également la mainmise de
paris sur le syndicat et déplore de ne
pas avoir été associé aux négociations
avec le groupe bolloré
ces élus au ce
qui ne sont pas d'accord avec cette
délibération vont se constituer dans un
collectif qui va déposer dans quelques
jours
un ou plusieurs coups au tribunal
extractif je pense qu'avant la fin il
fallait d'abord peut-être réactualiser
le fonctionnement la dsp et ça c'était
début 2017 qui vola unitaire puisque le
groupe bolloré a l'air et dès novembre
le montant du déficit qui effectivement
était justifiable de mesures de mesures
supprimer les stations qu'ils
fonctionnaient pas deuxièmement de
pouvoir au lieu de fermer les voies sur
berge
peut-être les laisser libres aux autos
l'ip aux voitures électriques ou votre
propre puisque j'avais cru comprendre
que les voitures électriques avait pour
vocation de permettre dans la ville de
paris de risquerait naturellement alors
d'une part on va garder les voitures qui
polluent
on va supprimer les voitures électriques
et comme il ya plus de voitures on vous
laisse rapatriés sur les vélos et ya
plus de vélos non plus donc aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il faut surtout que les
parisiens s'achèvent des bonnes
chaussures dès lundi prochain le nombre
de stations et de véhicules diminuera
progressivement à paris et en ile de
france
aucun calendrier n'a été encore
communiquée pour la ville du chesnay
selon philippe brillault en politique le
rassemblement national des yvelines ex
fn organisé ce dimanche à un barbecue
pour ses militants un rendez vous qui se
voulait fédérateur avant l'été et qui
s'inscrit dans une tournée nationale
après le changement nom du parti c'était
le 1er juin dans le département la
formation nourrit des ambitions en vue
des élections municipales
en 2020 le point avec nicolas landry et
nicolas kirillovitch un barbecue sur des
airs de tournée politique pour le
rassemblement national après le
changement de nos missions
remobilisation des militants et cadres
locaux alors que se profilent les
élections européennes mais surtout
municipal en 2020 le parti de marine le
pen espère nouer des alliances avec les
différents partis de droite
le département des yvelines pourrait
être une terre idéale pour ses ambitions
aujourd'hui nous nous sommes dans cette
démarche d'ouverture de rassemblement
nous voulons parler avec tous ceux qui
partagent notre vision c'est à dire que
la nation est le meilleur cadre
l'expression démocratique du peuple est
le meilleur cadre protecteur de notre
identité de notre prospérité économique
de nos solidarités et c'est je crois un
trait que nous avons en commun avec un
certain nombre de personnalités
politiques y compris dans ce département
il y a quatre ans l'ex front national
avait conquis à mantes-la-ville sa seule
mairie francilienne pour amplifier le
mouvement en 2020 le parti discute déjà
avec les représentants locaux de debout
la france et du parti chrétien démocrate
c'est dans les yvelines aussi que se
trouve la terre d'élection de jean
frédéric poisson très pragmatiquement
certaines personnes nous appellent en
disant voilà vous représentez tant de
points face à nourrir les personnes qui
ont vraiment salit la politique locale
donc il faudrait agir et donc ça c'est
des choses qu'on arrive tout à fait
entendre
donc voilà c'est en voie de réflexion
c'est comment après ans à ménages comme
on travaille tous ensemble malgré nos
divergences mais malgré aussi notre
entente sur l'essentiel
pour espérer conquérir plusieurs mairies
et asseoir son ancrage local le
rassemblement national devra largement
amélioré ses résultats électoraux dans
le département lors du premier tour de
la présidentielle le fn était arrivé
seulement en quatrième position derrière
notamment la france insoumise voyager
tout en restant dans sa classe à l'école
alain cavalier d'elancourt les ce1 et
cm1 cm2 ont découvert le monde grâce à
deux étudiants ils échangent
régulièrement par vidéo et par mail les
plus jeunes ont pu réaliser grâce à ces
échanges par dont un recueil de
souvenirs les plus grands un roman
d'aventurés reportage de mélanie poker
avec ce recueil
les voici incollable sur le monde ses
vingt-cinq élèves de ce1 de l'école
alain cavalier ou longuement travaillé
sur les pays
ça les a fait grandir alors ouvert
l'esprit alors effectivement on demande
beaucoup aux enfants de découvrir le
monde le monde qui les entoure mais bon
le monde un petit peu plus lointain
c'est un petit peu abstrait pour eux
donc grâce à ça c'était concret
comprenait quelques petites notes on a
été aussi faire quelques petites
recherches sur les tablettes ça nous a
permis un petit peu de trouver des
photos pour rajouter
il ya des traditions il ya des animaux
typique et à des plats traditionnels ya
aussi des faits très tristes ionel
touche que nous avons posé comme
question elle les a marqués et les
réponses que nous globe trotter ont fait
il les a marqués aussi les globe
trotters sont florian et antoine deux
étudiants partis autour du monde depuis
le mois d'octobre
ils échangent régulièrement par vidéo et
par mail déjà pour le
les beaux paysages en est plutôt bien là
on est au sud de l'afrique du sud et on
est juste une deuxième place et suivez
leur voyage les cm 1 et cm 2 e ou choisi
de créer un roman d'aventurés en basin
par cette lumière sous marin fluffy de
terribles megalodon diabolique avait
nagé jusqu'à l'un de ses repères situés
en afrique hashid un travail
d'imagination et de français une heure
par semaine
il conte les histoires de leila miiaou
il fluffy au delà du côté littéraire il
ya eu donc la dimension géographique
il ya eu un côté aussi
ce qu'on appelle chez nous et éducation
morale et civique donc avec le fait de
d'avoir la possibilité de découvrir
culturellement des peuples avec un mode
de vie très différent de celui que
connaissent les enfants attendent
maintenant le retour de florian et
antoine pour peut-être créer de nouveaux
romans le portrait de la semaine pour
refermer à ce journal a été désignée
sportive
iny monteyne de l'année mélanie chambrun
est archère au club de montigny le
bretonneux
à côté de cette activité elle est
également un écrivain et professeur de
français elle mélanie chambrun
intervient aussi dans les classes pour
sensibiliser à l'écriture et à la
lecture une rencontre signés camille
lambert et nicolas landry plus à droite
bien
du tir à l'arc l aveugle avec une
distance de 5 m mélanie chambre un
travail ses automatismes
objectif de cet exercice avoir
l'exécution parfaite en insistant sur
les détails
peux-tu couche bien là que tout ira bien
avec les omoplates et qu'ici ce soit
bien en contact et que ça dégage bien
derrière je l'enlève un sens elle a vu
dans le but de pouvoir vraiment se
concentrer sur chaque élément de son
corps après plus de 20 ans d'équitation
mélanie a commencé le tir à l'arc
il y a près de deux ans est fausse j'ai
cherché un sport que je pouvais
pratiquer j'avais un petit peu essayé de
tir à l'arc mais sans plus il ya
quelques années auparavant ça m'avait
bien plu j'ai un petit peu regardé je me
suis ni un club pas loin je vais
m'inscrire et ça m'a plu fréquence de
l'entraînement quatre cinq fois par
semaine avec son coach cyril au
programme techniques de tir répétition
du geste notamment sur la distance
olympique à 70 m et toujours le souci de
la précision
c'est qu'ils ne sacre et compétitrices
et qui en veut et qui en redemandent
même quand ça marche elle devait à vous
dire non ça marche pas c'est pas assez
bien c'est laissant peut pas lui en
vouloir
cette persévérance a permis à mélanie de
décrocher le titre de championne
départementale de tir à 50 m et la
médaille d'argent de tir à 70 m
aujourd'hui elle travaille
d'arrache-pied pour le championnat de
france prévu les 25 et 26 juillet
prochains
donc il faut que quand on lève l'arc
l'oeil ton qui ni si vous avez un point
rouge le point rouge doit les langues
jaune et ensuite on lâche
pourquoi est-ce qu'on choisit le titre à
la fin certains à mes élèves je leur dis
finalement leurs études c'est comme du
sport je sais bien qu'on français on
bien d'accord les exercices de grammaire
et de conjugaison personne n'a envie de
les faire mais il faut il faut passer
par là et c'est tout mais séance à 5 m
c'est comme leur les exercices alors je
parle du français c'est valable dans
toutes les matières quand mélanie
n'empêche pas ses flèches elle fait
découvrir son autre passion aux plus
jeunes l'écriture écrivain et professeur
de français dans un collège
elle intervient aussi dans des écoles
primaires durant les temps d'activités
périscolaires
elle accompagne ses élèves dans la
création d'un mur ils ont chacun leur
histoire avec leurs illustrations
vraiment qu'ils sont
voilà pour mettre en valeur leurs textes
et ils sont acteurs de az de leur propre
livre
on commence avec une feuille un stylo
l'idée est là ils vont vraiment écrire
c'est à dire qu'ils vont trouver leur
idée moi je vais les aider à construire
dans penser à hiérarchiser leurs
histoires pour que ça ait du sens
j'écris pour les enfants mais ça
m'intéressait de partager avec eux à la
fois des histoires la passion et leur
donner l'opportunité de le faire
eux-mêmes
depuis quatre ans elle a écrit dix
livres pour enfants trois livres sur
l'équitation
d'autres sont des premières lectures ou
encore une enquête se déroulant à royan
son prochain récit pourrait être
intitulé tina princesse rebelle
on a une jeune fille tina qui se
retrouve en 3ème année dans un dans un
pensionnat puisque c'est le passage
obligé pour devenir uniquement pour
scénariser aveu princes et aux
princesses
sauf que elle elle aimerait bien être
ailleurs la sortie de cet ouvrage est
prévue pour septembre 2018 avec comme
cible les 9 12 ans c'est la fin du set 8
journal belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]